[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle drôle d'année pourrait-on dire
comme on disait jadis eu la drôle de
guerre personnes auraient en effet
imaginé à la fin de l'année dernière
combien nos vies mais peut-être plus
encore la perception que nous avons de
l'existence à l'échangé ou contre cette
année à cause d'un petit virus venu de
chine
alors ensemble de revisiter cette année
ce retour sur les douze derniers mois va
nous faire comprendre les lois qu'on
demande et événements auxquels nous
n'attachons aucune importance ont changé
peut-être nos vies et combien d'autres
événements qui nous paraissait tout à
fait important sont finalement passés
inaperçus alors pour revenir sur cette
année noire celle que le tag 10 la pire
année de l'histoire mais qui recèle
peut-être quelques espoirs j'accueille
florence mercadé choqué contentez vous
vous êtes avocate au barreau de
versailles laurent mazaury bonjour dont
jean patrice est adjoint au maire
d'elancourt vice-président de 50 ans une
yvelines et président de cette scène
hadjar est désirable de claire bonjour
vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'université de rouen et c'est important
vous allez voir pourquoi stéphane
montangero jour est mangeable professeur
à l'université de versailles saint
quentin et doyen honoraire de cette
d'affecter n'doye jean baptiste duclair
bonjour vous êtes maître de conférences
à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin vincent
couronne vous êtes torv être enseignant
vous êtes spécifique du droit européen
avait fondé le mouvement de surligneurs
qui nous et nous nous montre comment
défectueuse peuvent arriver dans le
monde de la politique et jean charles
lajoie ni vous êtes vous êtes éditeur et
vous êtes aussi normand éditeurs normaux
presque prétendent est arrivé nous
aidera beaucoup en voilà et c'est
important parce que je salue outre les
téléspectateurs de tv 78,4 chaîne qui
relaye cette émission
canal 32 qui est la chaîne de troyes
dans l'aube lyon capitale celle de lyon
oui à la chaîne des hauts de france et
la chaîne normande bonjour donc et
bienvenue à tous les troyens ont donné
aux habitants d'autres français aux
normands qui ont la chance d'être
désormais représentée par amandine petit
la nouvelle miss france miss france 2000
21 est justement là voilà le magnifique
justement 7,7 ce héros cette élection de
miss france a été gâchée par des tweets
antisémites sur la parce que là l'une
des concurrentes étaient mist provence
je crois a dit que son père était
israéliens ce qui a provoqué une vague
de tweets antisémite
c'est là de fines absolument justement
ça pousse c'est un des problèmes qu'on
va évoquer qui a été évoqué dans cette
année c'est le déferlement de haine sur
les réseaux sociaux
la difficulté parce que les serveurs eux
mêmes ne supprime pas cessé ses tweets
ou c'est l'asie c'est un tweeter en
réalité qu est-ce que là il va falloir
un projet il y à des biais des projets
de loi pour éviter cette ce déferlement
de haine
commence alors mais il ya des projets de
loi sur les fameux article 24 et 18
maintenant qu'ils s'appellent plus
l'article 25 pour justement c'est au pcf
a stoppé en tout cas interpeller les
personnes qui sont à l'origine de
messages de haine et de dénonciation de
personnes en pouvant les identifier donc
non avec leur nom soit avec leur adresse
en appelant à la haine
là on l'espère sont des propos
antisémites et qui peuvent parfaitement
être poursuivis sur la base du canal tel
qu'il est à l'internet des besoins du
nombre de jeunes gens râlent gianni
bouvier intervenez là dessus oui oui
c'est bien évidemment tout à fait
scandaleuses qui me ce qui m'étonne un
peu c'est qu'encore une fois on va
placer le débat sur les réseaux sociaux
n'a pas posé
l'incompétence des modérateurs etc mais
le plus grave c'est qu'il sait que ces
messages soient émis par des gens pour
une population qui est actuellement
scandaleusement antisémites racistes
voir enfin tous les tous les défauts et
comme c'est un peu gênant peut-être de
savoir d'où ça peut venir et c'est à
dire oui c'est les réseaux sociaux les
réseaux sociaux ne sont qu'un moyen un
média s'il ya des gens derrière qui sont
des crapules immonde et de temps en
temps il faudra arriver à le dire et ne
pas essayer de noyer le label ed banger
ben oui il faudrait qu'il faudrait faire
la police sur facebook et sur twitter
non il faudrait empêcher ces abrutis et
s'exprimer il faudrait il faudrait faire
quelque chose il faut il faudrait
d'abord aussi qu'on les nomme un jour
qu'on arrive à dire d'où ça vient
parce qu'il ya des choses quand ça
arrive on dit ah bah oui mais sachez
d'extrême droite c'est ça c'est machin
c'est oh et puis quand ça danse et
d'antisémite il sait jamais d'où ça
vient personne n'ose dire nous séparons
du bon bord en plus élevé des réseaux
sociaux banon c'est plus grave que ça
mais de ne pas mettre un nom sur sur les
chaussées de l'anonymat n'est pas
forcément préserver laurent mazaury sur
ce je partage avec vous c'est la joie ni
le fait de devoir nommer les choses et
d'ailleurs on n'aime pas regarder nous
ne se pendre à les nommer
nommons lait ne l'ont l'est il ya deux
antisémitisme aux franciliens
d'antisémitisme historique j'allais dire
qu'il remonte pratiquement la
crucifixion du christ avec tout son
héritage limited chrétien je tiens on va
dire d'une forme d'extrême droite etc à
qui est inhérent quitteront qui passent
dans l'ensemble des électeurs de la
société qui est là qui avait maintenant
cliquez tout temps présent et il ya un
islamisme emporté réjean parent dont ali
said voyez ce lapsus il ya un an
this-is-not-it porté par une forme d'
islamiste ou d'islam aux gauchistes qui
vient des territoires occupés dont
d'ailleurs le camp delhi le breton vice
ligne 1 qui est porté par des gens en
france qui d'ailleurs si on leur
demandait l'histoire du conflit n'y
connaissent absolument rien il faut que
colporter ce qu'ils entendent sans
savoir même probablement situé où la
palestine et israël et qui utilisent
cela pour on va dire conglomérat ou
agglomérés autour d'eux un certain
nombre d'oppositions qui quelque part
lutte en réalité à travers
cet antisémitisme contre une nouvelle
fois les valeurs de la république et la
laïcité de la république qui sous tend
l'ensemble de religion donc c'est pour
moi encore plus grave que ce que je vois
est ce que j'entends alors nous
passionner un qui soit meilleur que
l'autre
il en est un qui est plus dans une
longue durée qu'il faut combat de
manière systématique de manière jaillir
patients il est visible au titre des
victimes de l' affaire dreyfus sont
exactement là exactement et une autre
qu'il faut combat devenir encore plus
efficace et plus rapide parce que lui
c'est un antisémitisme qui va même au
delà de l'antisémitisme il veut
combattre la démocratie et la république
française sur ce sujet notre
intervention vous passez à autre chose
internet oui pourquoi pas simplement
dire que déjà on est dans un paf sur les
notions de 2020 et je crois qu'on se
rend compte que finalement il n'y a pas
de leçons de 2008 dans ce genre de
épisode qui arrive en fin d'année où on
avait pu penser justement que cette
émission elle est aidée à mettre un
petit peu paillettes dans la dans la fin
d'année on se rend compte qu'on est
encore tristement par beaucoup appris
sur le vivre ensemble
alors je disais cette année était
surprenante juste tout petit extrait
l'espace est ce que la fin du discours
des manuels mâcon dont il a présenté ses
voeux pour 2020
c'était en décembre 2019 évidemment je
vous souhaite une très bonne année de
melgven vive la république vive la
france
c'était de la fin du discours
naturellement mais c'est vrai qu'il
avait parlé de la réforme de retraites
il avait parlé d'un certain nombre de
sujets évidemment pas de ce qui allait
arriver de ce que le times appelle la
pire année de l'histoire
stéphane morceau c'est peut-être exagéré
vous faire en cherchant bien et
peut-être pas très bas très longtemps et
pas de manière très approfondie
je suis sûr qu'on va trouver pire dans
l'histoire puis le tout est de savoir où
commence l'histoire
et puis ce qu'elle représente pour
chacun alors la pire année bon c'est je
ne sais pas c'est un slogan ou un effet
médiatique
je sais pas on trouvera peut-être des
gens pour lesquels
2020 a été une année magnifique après
tout mais c'est vrai que au regard de
considérations plus collective plus
générale c'est vrai que les motifs de
non satisfaction sont légion donc pire
année ç'a sûrement pas année très
particulière très révélatrice que ce
n'était pas des autres 1939 10 914
c'était pas terrible non plus que ce
n'était pas génial non
40 s'était pas ce n'était pas génial
enfin je veux dire le non plus mais
c'est vrai que on a toujours tendance à
penser que ce qu'on vit est la pire des
choses que dans des années vécues c'est
probablement le pire journal parce que
si je me trompe pas fait aussi le
journal qui a mis le modèle traoré en
tête en tête de gondole et donc voilà
quels que soient les une de ce journal
depuis quelques temps je pense que la
presse américaine est devenue folle et
le times en est devenu le l'étendard de
2,7 sous presse et de et de ses titres
ridicules les uns près des autres
ces personnalités qui vous tient le
clairet un événement d'une avenue et
voilà effectivement il ya bien pire que
ça donne et 2021
avant d'aborder elle l année mois par
mois et je voudrais vous interroger sur
la petit événement qui met en scène une
famille versaillaise on a parlé de
l'élection de miss france est d'aider
tout antisémite et c'est toujours
intéressant qu'on sur un événement de
variétés de divertissement il se passe
des choses peut être politique et c'est
super pour nous c'est la victoire de la
famille lefebvre dans l'émission la
france a un incroyable talent on va on
va les regarder se présenter puis ils
ont d'ailleurs commencé j'ai 22 ans et
je suis l'aînée de la famille et je fais
de chance depuis 8 ans moi c'est blanc
j'ai 21 ans je fais la musique au
conservatoire depuis que j'ai 8 ans que
je chante depuis cinq ans moi c'est
clément j 17 ans et je chante à la
maîtrise depuis huit ans alors moi c'est
emmanuel j'ai 15 ans et je chante à la
maîtrise notre âme diverses
et je fais de la flûte à bec moi je
m'appelle collonges et 12 ans et banque
du japon boj à l'interphone j'ai 8 ans
est la championne être donc je fais papa
de la famille je m'appelle gabriel et
j'ai une femme merveilleuse
donc moi je m'appelle and je suis à la
maman j'ai fait de la musique depuis que
je suis tout petit et je fais de la
direction de carreman voilà donc c'est
une famille versaillaise nombreuses
cathodique
c'est à dire le genre de famille dont la
télévision adore se moquer généralement
et quand on fait voter des
téléspectateurs et bien c'est elle qui
gagne
est ce que on peut avoir une lecture
politique de ce vote
ou est-ce que j'exagère si je dis ça je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas passer ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que de toute façon
été vision adore se moquer hyundai nous
adorons de moquer il faut vendre du
papier je pense au times tout à l'heure
et je partage ce que disait jean charles
mais c'est un peu la même logique il
faut vendre du papier il faut faire de
l'audience
donc effectivement on est là dans un
espèce d'archétypes ça n'enlève rien
d'ailleurs la qualité de la prestation
qui était de très bonne facture mais on
utilise de nous ils sont étonnants
l'outil des archétypes et et moi je
trouve éminemment sympathique mais on
pourrait prendre la même chose en vous
sortir les films des tuche on va aller
nous chercher les l'archétype des gens
du sud et puis qui voilà donc non pour
moi j'y vois pas de connotation
politique losophe par contre
effectivement des téléspectateurs
j'espère bien entendu que derrière tout
cela le vote est bien entendu respecter
suivi et que lille est contrôlé il est
pas forcément surprenant il ya une forme
de réaction politique spectateurs
adorent jouer aussi avec avec les
clichés donc bon j'y vois pas la chose
de politique mais j'y vois beaucoup de
choses de médiatique par vous les voyez
vous voyez pas là l'arrivée du général
de villiers au pouvoir et en particulier
d'ailleurs font les porte-parole de ça
ils pourraient être les symboles d'une
certaine france est ce que quelqu'un
veut l'interdire sur ce sujet oui moi je
voudrais dire une chose d'abord ce
concept le seul de cette noble
semblaient avoir suivi les aventures de
la famille lefebvre depuis le début
parce que c'est une émission que j'adore
et c'était franchement assez drôle et
surtout les premières fois comme vous le
dit très justement actrice le jury ait
commencé à se moquer en voyant cette
nuit effectivement un peu archétypique
et puis complètement séduits par le
franchement les champs lors qu'ils sont
certes pas ce entonné par les devants
par les rappeurs on est assez loin d'eux
on n'est pas du tout la paix dans le
monde mais c'était le jury départ
mocquard était tout à fait c'est dit et
donc après un parcours classique et donc
c'est qu'ils montent c'est tout à fait
mérité après on peut préférer le rap ou
préférez vous tapez sur des tambours et
être 50 chacun sait mais il ya sûrement
quand même que dit réaction et qu'on est
comme dans une époque ce qu'on fait la
rétrospective de l'année où tout ce qui
est disons que tous tout ce qui est
blanc d'un certain milieu etc
le quinquagénaire hétéro et tout de
suite j'ai di panda et là on a
effectivement une sa vie bat avec deux
beaucoup d'enfants il ya deux là donc je
pense que la veille les gens sony vient
de temps en temps voilà on est en train
de me critiquer ou peu vous peut
s'enthousiasmer pour quelque chose
et voilà c'est ce sexe en ce sens que
s'il ya peut-être un petit côté
politique là dedans un ras-le-bol une
certaine image
je voudrais me faire passer en
permanence dans les médias d'une france
qui n'est pas forcément celle que tout
le monde a envie de tout devoir et
appréciez donc levé c'est un signe en
tout cas et la victoire d'eads et de la
famille lefebvre coïncide aussi avec le
départ de jean pierre pernaut du 13h de
tf1 qui était aussi l'image d'une
certaine france tout en sachant
néanmoins qu'il était premier sur la
tranche des 25 qui d'habitude est plutôt
étrange et que l'on va chercher plutôt
dans les émissions je pense au rap dont
on parlait à l'instant
danon il était prévu sur les 25 35 ans
voilà réfléchissons à sk pas non plus
une forme de parisianisme contre la
province qui serait symbolisée par
versailles ce qui serait le comble mais
après tout ça devrait être historique
alors va commencer la rétrospective de
cette année et on va commencer par le
mois de janvier est évidemment alors
janvier il ya un événement qui parut et
qui peut-être va marquer l'année c'est
la sphère milan vous savez cette cette
jeune jeune fille qui a été victime
d'une violente campagne de harcèlement
pour avoir peur pour nous tenir des
propos jugés blasphématoires envers
l'islam
c'est vrai que c'est une affaire
symbolique de l'année celle là qui vous
commencez à charles peut-être fait c'est
tout à fait symbolique et c'est
absolument effrayant parce que weeds à
part vous qui la remet tait en valeur si
je puis dire
cette pauvre jeune fille est consigné
enfin assigné à résidence était obligé
de quitter le lycée militaire dans
lequel elle était abritée parce qu'elles
avaient été dénoncés parce qu'elle est
dénoncée à chaque fois qu elle pas
quelque part que ce soit en voyage
d'étude ou dans un lycée où les objets
de l'exfiltrer à chaque fois et tout ça
dans une sorte d'indifférence coupable
il n'y a pas un homme politique ou
quasiment pas qu'ils prennent sa défense
qui soit là parce que c'est et c'est ça
le véritable drame prenable son drame
personnel c'est à dire que ça arrive
aujourd'hui à millas mais ça va arriver
à ap l'un d'entre nous peut être l'année
prochaine ou dans deux ans et dans
l'indifférence générale yoro ba oui bah
oui la bécasse terre etc et et on est là
celle ci vit un véritable calvaire
et c'est ses adversaires ses ennemis de
vivre en toute impunité sont tranquilles
pérore se balade dans les médias etc
et cette pauvre jeune fille est
quasiment condamné avant on le sait bien
là je ne sais que faire pas mais elle a
au mieux un destin l'a salman rushdie
voilà ou à
l'auteur de gomorra enfin de dire que sa
tête est mise à prix et elle le dit elle
même elle sait très bien qu'elle ne
pourra pas s'en sortir
sa vie est foutue tue parce que la
démocratie française et la politique
française les deux petits français nous
sentions pas le courage de taper du
poing sur la table celle que jean michel
bloqué rassurer et louise d'éducation
assurait qu'elle trouvera un
établissement impôts poursuit ses études
mais c'est vrai que on a senti là aussi
et peut-être que le discours qu'a fait
emmanuel macron aux mureaux en désignant
l'islamisme radical est important sur ce
plan là on a senti en effet bad et des
années des différentes certains
défendant évidemment certains disant ben
non on peut pas blasphémer une religion
mais quand on est un peu sur le même
sujet que concernant miss france tout à
l'heure en réalité une certaine mesure
les choses il ya plusieurs niveaux il ya
là effectivement la réaction de ceux qui
disent qu'ils disent on n'a pas loin de
la semaine religion et qui du coup prend
de l'appel au meurtre en serait donc de
toute façon on n'a pas le droit de
prôner l'appel au meurtre et
particulièrement en france on a droit de
la semaine religion sommes dans une
république ici du siècle des lumières
oui on a le droit de critiquer toute
chose dans le respect du cadre de la loi
est là où effectivement je rejoins
encore monsieur lajoinie manqué de
courage
décidément manqué de courage politique
de les manquer de courage
d'un point de vue policier et manquer de
courage un point de vue juridique
c'est à dire que on retombe toujours sur
cette problématique aujourd'hui qu'on va
probablement un jour effectivement que
me disait ma collègue tout à l'heure
prenez nouvelle loi mais on a déjà les
lois nécessaires pour faire condamner
ces gens là il faut avoir effectivement
le courage politique de le faire mais il
faut avoir le courage politique
d'arrêter et poireaux à jouer type de
poursuivre et il faut avoir les moyens
financiers de condamnés à des peines
qu'ils soient effectivement effectué est
appliquée parce qu'on le sait tous très
bien aujourd'hui on a pour des raisons
économiques et financières que l'on peut
comprendre par ailleurs une vraie
problématique pour appliquer les peines
donc bien une grande partie de ces gens
se moquent bien de pouvoir lancer des
anathèmes condamné à mort n'importe qui
vous voir même d'ailleurs parfois de
passer à l'acte comme on a pu le voir je
pense
monsieur halimi par exemple y avait
quand même été victimes de crimes
racistes très clairement identifiés par
la même frange que ceux qui condamnent
aujourd'hui cette jeune fille seven
mention sur ce sujet non je nuance je
nuance pas sûr sur la liberté que nous
avons et fort heureusement de mettre en
cause les dogmes religieux y compris de
manière de manière grossière comme ça a
été le cas de cette jeune fille c'est
son droit de dire quelle qu'elle veut
quelques mâles alors ifis annales du
prophète
elle a absolument le droit de le faire
ce qu'on n'a pas le droit de dire en
revanche c'est que c'est qu'elle sait
d'insulter les adeptes d'une ce dogme
cette religion ce qu'elle n'a pas fait
mais je veux je nuance tout même sur la
réponse à la fois la réponse politique
et la réponse juridique
la classe politique n'a pas été unanime
dans le soutien qu'elle aurait pu
apporter aux agresseurs ou à ceux qui
l'ont menacé et de surcroît les
institutions ont réagi puisque les
condamnations ont déjà été prononcées
notamment à l'égard de plusieurs
plusieurs de ces dossiers personnes qui
quittent ils l'ont menacée soit
d'ailleurs en direct soit soit à
distance
il ya eu déjà des condamnations ont été
prononcées
quant à la question de l'exécution des
peines là aussi c'est autre chose mais
il faut être beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
prudent que cela on sait que on a
toujours une une une vision trop
caricatural enfin florent ce serait
mieux qualifier pour le pour le pour le
dire mais les peines sont si j'ose dire
beaucoup plus et beaucoup mieux exécuter
que l'entend parfois où on veut bien le
dire
dans le débat politique interne bezina
est ce que justement enfin dans cette
affaire et puis on peut le rapprocher
enfin du discours que prononcera
emmanuel macron alors ça sera plus tard
le 2 octobre de cette année aux mureaux
est ce qu'il n'ya pas et et on le voit
peut-être dans cette affaire me lardans
ses hésitations
est ce que il faut pas rattraper des
années des années de laisser faire on
reparle toujours de la sphère de creil
c'est en 1989 les certificat de
virginité et cetera ya des médecins qui
disait bah oui il faut quand même le
faire
est-ce qu'on n'a pas pris beaucoup de
retard quand même danse dans cette lutte
contre contre l'islamisme radical
alors je me permettre de faire un petit
retour parce que c'est vrai que je
voulais intervenir notamment sur un
point de la ferme il a que je trouve
qu'on ne met pas assez en lumière c'est
que c'est une affaire qui certes fait
exploser le discours entre ces jeunes là
parce que ça s'est passé sur les réseaux
mais ça dit beaucoup aussi du
harcèlement qui est possible sur ce type
de média c'est à dire qu'auparavant se
faire tirer les cheveux à la récré
c'était le pire qu'on pouvait imaginer
du d'isolement social alors que
maintenant avec ce type de vecteurs là
on peut ruminer la vie de certains
adolescents et je trouve que si on
manque de pénalisation c'est peut-être
quand même sur cette question du
harcèlement sur les raisons parce que
c'est vrai qu'on parle de plus en plus
du harcèlement au lycée mais il faut
quand même en parler aussi à l'aune de
ce que permettent ces médias avec le
type de retentissement qui est qui est
le leur sur le point de savoir si on a
été en retard moi je ne suis pas sûr que
ce soit un retard de notre législation
par exemple sur les types de réponses
juridiques ou même quelque chose qui
soit due à une incapacité politique j'ai
l'impression que le phénomène évolué et
que l'histoire elle-même amène chaque
année plus de frustration et donc chaque
année peut-être plus de revendications
et chaque année finalement plus de haine
donc moi j'ai le sentiment que c'est pas
tellement un retard que nous payons que
le fait qu' il ya une
internationalisation une
un durcissement de ces phénomènes de
violence dans les discours entre les
religions mais aussi entre les manières
de vivre et que finalement ce qu'on est
incapable de maintenir c'est c'est une
loi commune
alors on a parlé de la laïcité tout à
l'heure mais mais finalement c'est le
grand concept d'ordre public c'est à
dire cette idée d'être ensemble et est
ce qui fait un petit peu mal dans ce cas
riode de l'année 2020 manifeste bien la
pandémie les risques de violence les
débordements cessé de se dire que
finalement la france est avec elle
beaucoup d'autres pays du monde ont du
mal à trouver un dogme suffisamment
commun pour arriver à fédérer
et pour arriver à sentir qu'on vit
ensemble en dehors des périodes de coupe
du monde c'est vrai qu'à pas vraiment de
des langues nationales il ya peut-être
de moins en moins de sentiment de
communauté et je pense que c'est
vraiment là qu'il faut essayer pas
tellement même de rattraper un retard
mais de marteler une conviction et
d'essayer d'aller d'aller plus loin dans
dans cette question alors quand tu es
avec le mois de janvier
le 23 janvier trois cas de coronavirus
sont signalés en france
est ce que vous vous souvenez vincent
couronne par exemple notre notre analyse
de ce corner verizon se disait combat
bord c'est loin c'est une petite
gripette c'est pas grand chose devenait
de ça un mois je me souviens très bien
de cette période blanc et bien
effectivement il faut pas qu'on ait la
mémoire courte
à l'époque il y avait quelques personnes
qui alertés
et puis de nombreuses personnes qui
disaient que ça n'était qu'une petite
gripette il a fallu du temps plusieurs
jours dure semaine pour que pour que
l'idée d'un virus vraiment dangereux
fasse son chemin
donc on s'est toujours facile a
posteriori de juger en fait les actes et
les positions qu on a pu prendre à une
époque où il faut quand même se souvenir
que déjà l'état des connaissances
scientifiques étaient extrêmement
lacunaires à l'époque il était encore
dans le monde aujourd'hui mais en tout
quand il s'est calmé beaucoup plus je
reprends l'exemple du vaccin il ya une
information qui circule en ce moment
comme quoi le vaccin était prêt en fait
depuis le mois de janvier
oui il y avait des prototypes de vaccins
qui était prêt depuis le mois de janvier
mais simplement au mois de janvier
personne n'aurait accepté conteste un
vaccin concours n'appliquant vaccin à ce
que la population mondiale sans l'avoir
testé pendant des mois sans sens au sens
d'avoir cherché les potentiels effets
secondaires etc
et donc c'est ce courrier tout cette
tendance avec le recul du temps à
oublier parfois quel était l'état de
l'opinion publique
parce que c'est aussi important et
l'état des connaissances à un instant t
et c'est vrai que quand on a eu les
premiers cadres pour aux navires us sur
le territoire il ya eu un petit effet de
panique mais qui était pas forcément
qu'il n'est pas encore généralisée alors
va passer au mois de février avec pas
mal d'actualité notamment une actualité
parisienne il va avoir des conséquences
sur cette année alors février d'abord eu
le 13 février la démission vous savez de
l'académie des césars des suites de la
sphère me dauphin de nouveau mis tout c
est pourtant aux césars et bien roman
polanski sera consacré meilleur
réalisateur ce qui va provoquer
évidemment une polémique très fort le
départ d'un certain nombre d'actrices et
puis on appris au mois de septembre que
l'académie des césar
avait avait remis dans leur dans leurs
académies et roman polanski qu'il
n'avait pas participé à la dernière
cérémonie et thomas langmann qui avait
été condamné pour harcèlement
donc ils sont à nouveau membre de cette
académie et comme a dit béatrice dalle
c'est du foutage de gueule beaucoup de
beaucoup d'hésitation pour pas grand
chose au fond on peut dire ça va passer
non mais on peut pas s'arrêter c'est
évidemment sur tous les événements -
volant vous le dira mot là-dessus où on
passe au plus tôt à cette affaire qui
est quand même à mon avis intéressante
c'est le 15 février
le benjamin griveaux renonce à se
présenter à la mairie de paris à la
suite de la publication d'une vidéo à
caractère sexuel anouar ben bella du
caire je crois que c'est un événement
qui vous intéresse alors c'est un
événement qui m'a profondément intéressé
entend constitutionnalise sur ce que
sahamies quand même du débat politique
et de la manière dont finalement dans
une campagne on s'arrête alors il y
avait déjà eu la sphère françois fillon
qui avait fait que pendant la campagne
on a plus une seule fois à discuter du
projet politique d'un des candidats et
qu'on a même plus une seule fois discuté
des projets politiques des candidats
mais qu'on a été focalisé sur une
affaire judiciaire
mais là on descend encore plus bas et je
trouve que la sphère griveaux a signé
peut-être la fin d'une confiance dans le
peut-être même d'un certain respect à la
classe politique dans le sens où il ya
eu vraiment cette idée même qui a pu
prospérer par ce fameux piotr
anderszewski je sais même plus comment
il s'appelle pas blême ski sûrement
cette idée que on pouvait politiquement
combattre quelqu'un
en allant justement fouiller dans des
vidéos de ce caractère là donc il ya eu
il ya eu finalement pour moi une
dégradation absolue du discours et puis
quelque chose qui relève aussi de la
délégitimation de de ce propos en disant
mais ils n'avaient qu'à pas jouer les
pères de famille durant sa campagne qui
m'a semblé totalement choquant est
finalement peut-être ou annonciateur
d'une fin d'un discours politiques qui
vont être apaisés justement va sans
couronne sur sur 7 sur cette attaque
dont a été victime quand même benjamin
griveaux on s'est interrogé sur la
liberté d'expression est ce que est ce
que publier des vidéos comme ça ça fait
partie de la liberté d'expression banon
et c'était intéressant de voir qu'à
l'époque
piotr pas prennent ce qu'ils étaient un
commentaire résident est en france parce
qu'il ne pouvait plus vivre en russie
le pont pour effectivement sa liberté
d'expression n'a pas été largement
entravé et il s'est plaint malgré tout
qu'en france il ne puisse pas quand on
attaque parce qu'une plainte a été
déposée contre lui pour avoir diffusé
cette vidéo de benjamin thiebaux or la
liberté d'expression france elle a ses
limites
comme partout en europe et notamment ici
c'était la question d'atteinte à la vie
privée on ne peut pas délibérément porté
atteinte à la vie peut aider quelqu'un
et parce que face à la liberté
d'expression il yad'autres liberté avec
laquelle il faut pouvoir l'a consignée
et benjamin brivot griveaux pardon dans
sa vie privée à des libertés qu'il doit
pouvoir aussi préservée après sur la
question de l'inadéquation entre son
discours public et sa vie privée eh bien
il ya des tas d'autres manières des
enquêtes journalistiques et même un
artiste vous tout à fait arrivée à
dénoncé sans forte forcément atteinte à
la vie privée de d'une personne publique
donc d'ailleurs je trouve que là
la réaction souvent des parisiens parce
que là on parle ici d'une élection
municipale parisienne à l'époque a été
assez assez intéressante la plupart des
gens avec il n'en parlait disait mais
après tout on s'en fiche un petit peu au
fait de la vie privée de benjamin
griveaux et certains avaient même
exprimé leur souhait de le voir
continuer 1 malgré tout pour montrer que
justement en fait aidé jean fauque un
petit peu de ce genre de seconde de
bisbee face à des chocs payer pardon oui
ce qui est troublant dans cette affaire
au delà de tout ce que vous venez de
dire de façon tout à fait intelligent
c'est c'est un peu là la bêtise et dire
de benjamin griveaux qui se voyaient
enfin été probablement promis un assez
grand l'avenir politique et qui ne
comprend pas que coton on aspire à ce
genre de rôle on balance pas des vidéos
pornos à n'importe qui a une maîtresse
d'un jour on connait pas sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est plutôt ça qui me choque
parce qu'après effectivement comme lui
très justement ils fassent qui veut bon
j'ai des recettes chacun sont chacun 7
et je ne juge pas sa femme et qu'il
n'ait pas compris qu'un homme politique
ne peut pas avoir la vie de monsieur
tout le monde ou jojo le routier en
annonçant ces vidéos sur sur facebook
c'est ça que je ne comprends pas cessé
de s'améliorer surtout d'une totale au
monde actuel et le type ne comprend pas
alors soit il était raide amoureuse et
qu'elle veut dire mais sinon voilà c'est
pour ça que ça avait été partagée parce
qu'on a été très dure avec les réseaux
sociaux jusqu'à présent que c'est vrai
qu'il ya un vrai problème de législation
mais en l'occurence n'était pas un
problème de modération des réseaux
sociaux une conversation d'ordre privé
ce qui est encore plus choquant
justement d'un point de vue juridique
mais il y aurait surtout d'une thèse à
faire sur le sentiment d'impunité de
certains hommes politiques qui sont
aubrée parce que il pour ce crime
pourrait leur arriver et et griveaux en
est un exemple me n'est pas le premier
et de loin france
zem politique on se le pouvoir c'est
pour faire un parallèle avec benjamin
griveaux mais le pouvoir c'est comme du
viagra
c'est une espèce de la voilà donc je
pense que si ça donne une impression de
surtout si on a un élu avec nous
interroger sur autre chose parce que
cette affaire qui vous c'est quand même
le début c'est la démission aussi danis
besoins du ministère de la santé
la nomination d'olivier veyrat est
peut-être le début d'un d'une défiance
des français vis-à-vis du pouvoir parce
qu'il va y avoir toute cette
communication un peu bizarres sur les
masques sur les tests etc
c'est aussi ça la démission de bérigaud
oui mais ça fait c'est ça date pas de
benjamin griveaux cette défiance des
français vis à vis a dit que la messe de
la santé l'avait peut-être autre chose à
faire que d'aller se présenter à la
mairie de paris en face à lui étaient
reprochés oui mais je pense que là elle
a été poussée vers la mairie de paris
s'est pas je pense pas que c'était son
souhait à l'origine de se rendre à la
mairie de paris
d'autant plus que c'était complètement
suicidaire de la part d' en marche
d'envoyer à agnès buzyn caezar et donc
je pense que cette défiance notamment
par exemple par rapport à benjamin
griveaux ci ont commencé à fouiller dans
la vie privée de tous les hommes
politiques
benjamin griveaux il serait pas le seul
parce qu'on voit bien déjà sur le passé
d'un certain nombre d'hommes politiques
de ces dépôts lui demander je suis le
maintien concerne aussi les femmes
politiques oui j'ai quelques années
à rivaliser avec la succulente les
hémicycles pouvoir genre de chose voler
dans les hautes sphères on se rend plus
compte de ce qu'on fait les maîtres vous
avez tout à fait raison c'est toujours
été le pouvoir le sexe et l'argent enfin
c'est ce qu'ils dominent le monde et
qu'il fait fonctionner dans le cas de
benjamin griveaux la vraie problématique
c'est qu'il était assez gogo pour penser
qu'effectivement que ça ne sortirait pas
et qui ne se soit pas rendu compte de la
manipulation mais à part ça et après les
événements en cascade
on va aller plus loin également s'assure
la victoire d'anne hidalgo il salua sur
peut-être même une candidature à la
présidentielle
oui si on recule cyr la logique jusqu'au
fond bien dans les voilages et médias
voilà une petite vidéo comme ça il ya eu
des conséquences absolument incroyable
on va passer au mois de mars
évidemment est le mois de mars ba c'est
le premier confinement et les
municipales
[Musique]
alors jean baptiste et duclair le
premier confinement vous souvenez
comment cette arrivée est ce que est ce
que ça a été c'est vrai que tout le
monde était un peu sidérée une fois
qu'on a été confiné bah oui
effectivement cette sidération elle
succède à ce que décrivent et toutes à
leurs instances c'est à dire qu'on était
au départ n'aura une phase qui était de
7,2 de la curiosité tout il y avait il
faut le rappeler aussi cette
désinformation qui a better extrait par
la chine sur la naissance du virus là
bas et c'est ça en fait qui a généré
cette espèce de le moment de flottement
en fait de sueur en france mais
évidemment dans le dans toute l'europe
il ya un détail en particulier
et puis bah effectivement donc il a
fallu ensuite face à la montée en ciel
du virus prendre des mesures qui ont été
d'ailleurs réalisé devenir culte a fait
sous peine de manière tout à fait subi
une langue lorsque la nouvelle a été
annoncée
on était tous sidérés moi je me souviens
que des mises à circuler sur les réseaux
sociaux et des textos chacun connaissait
cain qui connaissent quelqu'un qui était
le ministère de l'intérieur vous venez
d'annoncer des dizaines de millions de
morts
lahoud au bizet que déjà un quai dans
complotisme et que tout ça était
orchestrée d'en haut pour manipuler les
gens et pourquoi alors revenir renier
leur liberté c'était un moment
extrêmement particulier puis à slade
avance ajouter des élections municipales
là aussi j'ai eu un moment de flottement
puisqu'il ya des contenants qui était
d'organiser et puis en même temps ce
grand moment de démocratie
il me semble d'ailleurs qu'à l'époque le
président a public était défavorable au
maintien de cette élection et sous la
contrainte des partis politiques ou en
tout cas majeure partie d'entre eux
effectivement ces élections étaient
organisées je crois qu'après coup on a
un petit peu regretté compte tenu
notamment du nombre de quatre victimes
et est alors je ne vois pas la
chronologie des événements 12 mars donc
le président macron annonce que le pays
sera confiné à partir du 17 mars le 14
mars
edouard philippe annonce la fermeture
des lieux recevant du public non
indispensables à la vie du pays
c'est recommencer à parler d' essentiel
pas essentiel donc les établissements
scolaires seront également fermés le 22
mars le parlement adopte la loi
instaurant un état d'urgence sanitaire
le 27 mars le confinement est prolongée
jusqu'au 15 avril
le 7 avril la france dépasse la barre
des 7000 morts
et puis vous savez qu'à 20 heures les
français ont pris l'habitude d'aller sur
les balcons pour applaudir les soignants
et le 13 avril confinement et prolongée
des escrocs 11 mai alors revenons un
instant justement sur ces municipales
vous étiez candidat
il ya eu évidemment une abstention
neuf tensions très fortes beaucoup
d'élections au premier tour dont la voix
est aussi dans la nôtre absolument c'est
un moment un petit peu lunaire d'abord
parce que moi personnellement non papa
décédé du coc vide quelques temps après
il était déjà malade avait déjà été
atteint en fait on ne savait pas de quoi
et donc on était un peu la peur au
ventre et ça je voudrais que l'on s'en
souvienne
ne pas oublier effectivement que une
partie ne souhaitait pas que ces
élections aient lieu on était prêt à les
reporter puisqu'en fait on avait en ce
qui nous concerne et beaucoup de listes
l'ont fait arrêter la campagne
pratiquement quatre semaines avant c'est
la korité on a fait une campagne d'une
semaine et le résultat en est resté chez
nous pas le cas tout est lisse mais
beaucoup l'ont fait donc on avait
vraiment le sentiment d'une angoisse et
le jour d'élection
on avait beau avoir eu quelques moyens
qui avait il nous avait été donné les
masses du gf on n'a rien inventé
c'était déjà le cas on a passé une
journée d'angoissé et dans une certaine
mesure avec un taux de participation
faible on était presque un peu rassuré
parce qu'on s'est dit qu'on était moins
exposé via c'est du concret un peu vrai
mais c'est du concret qui sont elles
étaient donc après effectivement
beaucoup listes ont été élus au premier
tour et puis rappelons nous il s'est
posé ensuite la question de savoir mais
quand aura lieu le deuxième pas eu lieu
comme il aurait une vingtaine annulés le
premier tour et faire voter tout le
monde voilà on est parti quand même dans
des semaines de débat et je tiens à
rappeler d'ailleurs on en parlait
discrètement il ya quelques instants que
effectivement le présent la pluie qui
était pour le report des élections c'est
le cas d'edouard philippe également la
pression a été beaucoup misé par gérard
larcher personnel pour que les lieux
alors dans un but effectivement de
favoriser le renouvellement des équipes
etc qui a toujours un petite dose de
politique d à tout ça mais ça a été un
vrai débat au sein de la classe
politique et des électeurs également
c'est pas de mention vous dirais que ce
sont des élections au rabais non nous ne
nous non ce ne sont pas des élections au
rabais il n'y a pas en démocratie
d'élections d'élections au rap et le le
corps électoral le peuple fait ce qu'il
veut de cet outil démocratique important
il ya eu du contentieux d'ailleurs
certains certaine liste perdante qui ont
attaqué demandé au juge administratif
l'annulation de des résultats du scrutin
du fait d'une abstention très élevé une
abstention très forte elle jugé j'allais
dire évidemment son plan juridique assez
compréhensifs aussi sur le plan
démocratique le juge urgent est de tels
arguments
il ya eu je vais pas un taux de
participation chez couper les têtes qui
tournait aux alentours de 30%
tant pis il ya de mon point de vue il
n'ya pas d'élection rappel
sa cause d'autres questions bien entendu
mais une élection reste reste un outil
démocratique fondamental y compris avec
des dés marée électoral de participation
aussi aussi faible aussi basse alors va
passer one met tout doucement un voile
mais c'est bah c'était le déconfinement
et puis on a parlé beaucoup de soucis du
déboulonnage des statuts en cours se
voit la wii alors déconfinement donc et
qui arrivent il ya un monsieur
déconfinement qui s'applique aux
personnes ne connaissent et qui
s'appelait monsieur jean castex 1
ça a été alors là on a l'impression
qu'il ya quand même une libération quand
on a payé peut-être à la suite après
après ce confinement qui nous avait tous
sidérés on ne savait pas très bien où
les gens restés chez eux quand même avec
quand même peur de ce qui se passait il
ya on a le pré sur une impression qu'on
avait vaincu le virus
et c'est sans doute une impression
québec était mauvaise et et et kid ou
dont on paye les conséquences encore
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on l'a tous vécu
de la même façon on a eu très peur et
puis ensuite c'est un petit peu quand on
enlève là on enlève là le couvercle sur
la casserole qui est en train de
bouillir évidemment l'os hôte et
s'évapore et effectivement et qui plus
est je rajouterais un petit peu quelques
messages gouvernement qui était un petit
peu pas très clair cela veut dire
profitez de vos vacances et les vacances
un petit peu alesi respecter les gestes
barrières les partis en vacances donc
effectivement un certain nombre de gens
se sont libérés après après je suis pas
certain de jouer d'un certain que si on
avait tout de suite mis en place plus de
respect des gestes barrières on
n'ai eu de meilleurs résultats en termes
tout cas de gens contaminés de personnes
décédées etc
on se souvient des primates y voir les
masques pendant pratiquement trois mois
on se souvient des problématiques pour
se faire tester et puis après il faut
qu'on a parlé de se faire tester les
gens se détester mais et quoi d'autre
c'est à dire on s'isole
ou comment on nous contraint à nous
isoler je vois ti je vais pas revenir
sur ce qui se continue encore
aujourd'hui éducation nationale une
personne est qu'à contacter pas de alors
nos entreprises c'est 2 on voit bien que
on peut comprendre on peut comprendre
cette volonté de sortir etc
mais je pense qu'on peut donner de leçon
à personne le président est malade au
genre demi il aurait pu très bien
contaminé cet été parce qu'il voit
beaucoup de gens je dois dire que c'est
un pas si mathématiquement on voit des
gens qui ont de la chance d'être
contaminés qu'on soit protégé ou pas en
tout cas bouffée d'oxygène de pouvoir en
sortir c'est absolument évident sur le
déboulonnage je cite elle parce que la
sphère côté du site une déclaration
récente des manuels macron qui dit on
m'a parfois traité de brutes épaisses
parce que j'étais contre les débuts de 9
des statuts
je ne crois pas à la con de cette
culture je ne crois pas à l'effacement
de ce qu'on est par contre ce qui est
vrai c'est qu'il ya toute une part de
notre histoire collective qui n'est pas
représenté qui peut être contre cette
idée gens semblent nombreuses
le président macron a tout à fait raison
après oui on peut multiplier comme ça
rechercher des écrivains recherché
d'aidé qui serait issu de la diversité
mais encore une fois je déteste
tellement ce truc de la diversité parce
que quand on parle de diversité ça
voudrait dire que moi je serai issu
d'une et monte uniformité puisque je ne
fais pas partie apparemment de la
diversité donc voilà ça j'en ai marre un
peu de ce concept de diversité qui ne
veut rien dire
effectivement est un écrivain de
couleurs qui composent honorer un or on
le voit là mais on va pas non plus
passer l'année là dessus on voit bien
qu'ils sont les gens derrière ça plus
l'identité française je vais un peu vite
mais un tout petit mot moins fort sur
ces déboulonnage simplement dire quelle
tristesse de n'avoir que que le passé à
refaire si on n'a pas l'avenir a créé je
veux dire c'est le symbole d'une
population qui va quand même très mal et
là aussi on vient sur les concepts de
vivre ensemble on a quand même du coût
des uns contre les autres donc ceux qui
sont les opprimés ceux qui sont les
oppresseurs et ça signifie qu'en plus il
faudrait que l'histoire elle-même en
soit coupable donc du coup je trouve que
là aussi on était un peu dans le même
climat avec cette période là c'est à
dire que l'on n'a plus d'avenir on est
en train de re jugé la conformité à
notre présent de notre passé est très
dangereux alors on va passer au mois de
juin de juillet et d'août le coup mais
parce que et juillet-août 10 passes un
peu moins de choses mais enfin on va
parler du référendum de jean castex et
de gérald darmanin référendum puisque le
26 juin ben c'était la commission
citoyenne sur le climat qui remettait
ses 149 propositions on sait depuis que
le président de la république va enfin
un référendum
c'est l'article 89 qui s'applique donc
il faut que les deux assemblées vote le
texte de manière identique
est ce que c'est un piège pour la droite
modérée a peut-être jean baptiste
duclair oui effectivement alors il ya
deux procédures qui s'offrent au
président de la république il ya la voie
normale celle qui est conforme à la
constitution et qui est l'article 89 un
référendum de passe par le parlement
avec un vote directement des français ou
l'adoption du parcours du congrès
c'est-à-dire la réunion des deux
parlements ou celle autre possibilité
qui était offert par la voir l'article
11 de la constitution qui avait
d'ailleurs été un temps envisagée bien
nous avons par le premier qui n'a pas
été sa préférence alors évidemment pour
que la f1 dom soit porté jusque devant
les français il faut qu'il y ait un pote
identique de l'assemblée nationale tina
la difficulté étant évidemment que le
sénat est à droite et que donc ce qui
met en la droite en position délicate
puisque si jamais elle décidé de ne pas
suivre le président on pourrait lui
reprocher de ne pas avoir pour
préoccupation l'environnement donc il ya
évidemment très certainement de la
tactique
un politique dans ce dessein et il sera
intéressant de voir justement comment la
droite pas réagir
je pense à mon avis que elle va mettre
en avant des tacticiens de la chose ne
serait ce parce que l'environnement est
déjà présente dans notre constitution
avec une charte de l'environnement et
notamment l'article 1 de la constitution
il ya pas longtemps une décision du tout
sexy
je n'ai pu regagner du nom aussi patrice
on peut peut-être gagner du temps alors
juillet démission d'edouard philippe et
nomination de jean castex
avec le recul on se demande pourquoi
avoir remplacé un quelqu'un qui était ou
dans les sondages par un haut
fonctionnaire qui avait raté de
déconfinement nom pourrait poser la
question comme ça c'est moche patrie
c'est moche mais c'est à des reproches
qu'on a faits voilà non mais je pense
qu'il y avait de toute façon besoin d'un
deuxième souffle ça ça me semble une
évidence je pense bon jeu par les grands
secrets qu edouard philippe était pas
non plus un candidat à rester beaucoup
plus longtemps
je pense qu'il avait d'autres visées au
havre et c'est pas une plaisanterie il
faut avoir cet ancrage local si on vise
d'autres choses plus tard je pense qu'il
est arrivé à un moment donné où il
souhaitait de toute façon laissé la
place donc le présent lui a donné raison
en même temps il y avait une une volonté
d'avoir une gestion un peu plus
administrative delà de ce qu'on pensait
être à ce moment là une sortie de crise
puisque tout allait mieux j'aurais pas
deuxième n'y aurait pas de troisième
pack on n'envisageait pas et donc qui
mieux que le responsable de
déconfinement pour être premier ministre
après encore une fois on juge dans
l'histoire ont testé va donner son âme
on verra rapidement est ce que ben c'est
pas symbolique au fond d'eux de la vème
république avec le quinquennat c'est à
dire que le président cependant en
première ligne était une sorte de grand
directeur de cabinet qui devient le
premier ministre on se souvient de de ce
l'appellation de collaborateurs qui
avaient été conférée à françois fillon
par par sarkozy alors c'est vrai que
dans dans
dans l'esprit des institutions de la
vème ne sais pas le cas mais dans leur
pratique
en effet ça le devient alors tout dépend
aussi à la fois de la personnalité du
premier ministre et puis tout dépend de
son poids politique le poids politique
de jean castex
il est proche de zéro celui de d'edouard
philippe en revanche il était au regard
en tout cas de sa popularité il devenait
important et probablement aussi trop
important puisque il avait plutôt
tendance à commencer à faire de l'ombre
au président de la république m'enfin
souvenez-vous de françois fillon
françois fillon a été premier ministre
pendant cinq ans pendant toute la durée
du quinquennat donc il ya en effet aussi
le bon mécanisme du fusible même et je
rejoins ce que disait ce que disait
laurent basauri qu'il fallait il fallait
politiquement à second souffle et
faisons souffle il se manifeste d'abord
par par ce type de par ce type de
changement souffle visiblement non sait
jamais mais si emmanuel macron se
trouvait dans l'impossibilité de se
représenter la candidature d'edouard
philippe s'imposerait à ce moment là
faire de politique fiction je pose que
le je pense que le président de
république sera très attentif à ce que
diront les sondages dans les mois qui
s'approchant des élections on va passer
au moins 10 septembre de ce mois de
septembre et alors septembre nous
reparler de christophe castaner qui est
élu président de groupe
lrm face à aurore bergé député de la
circonscription des yvelines
castrés raté obligé de partir du mi5
l'intérieur parce que il a une phrase
que ne supporte pas les policiers elie
et du racisme dans la police il ya deux
choses que ne supporte pas les policiers
il faut pas eu de violences policières
comme s'ils n'existaient pas et qu'on
parle de racisme dans la police comme
s'il n'existait pas sans dire que tous
les policiers sont violents ou racistes
et sexistes quand même mais pourquoi on
ne peut pas le dire
là dessus si je peux me permettre il ya
joe quoi il ya là il faut nuancer
peut-être un petit peu propose est à
dire qu'il n'ya pas des mots à ne pas
dire mais il ya quand même une tradition
historique qui veut que le ministre de
l'intérieur on l'appelle souvent le club
premier flic de france
ça prouve quand même que le ministre de
l'intérieur a un rôle un peu comme le
ministre de la justice est un peu comme
le ministre de l'éducation il y à un
forme de corporatisme
c'est à dire qu'un ministre c'est
l'article 20 de la prostitution est
avant tout le chef d'une administration
et donc il se doit d'être en quelque
sorte
hoyau avec ses équipes et quand bien
même ces équipes ont mal agi
il est toujours celui qui va essayer de
les défendre ou de porter leur voix donc
à partir du moment où quelque part le
ministre de l'intérieur qui est le chef
du bateau qui ce navire quelques mois
plus tard le président de la république
fait pas vraiment beaucoup mieux il ya
quand même une forme de sentiment d'être
lâché qui peut qu'il peut exister dans
ce type de corporations et je crois
vraiment indépendamment des mots qui ont
été 10 et c'est avant tout cette
mutation du rôle du ministre de
l'intérieur qui essaie peut-être pas la
bienvenue ou qui en tout cas mérite
d'être questionné quoi yahia il ya eu un
gars passe à ce niveau-là pense pas que
le fait de nommer quelque chose qui
existe
fasse que monsieur castaner quitte le
navire
je ne crois pas du tout au contraire il
veut essayer de d'orienter peut-être le
navire comme tout chef 20 chefs
d'entreprise si vous pouvez pas nommer
quelqu'un qui fait du racisme dans votre
équipe et de pouvoir en tirer les
conséquences je pense que la chef
d'equipe il se doit de les essayer
d'avoir une unité eu d'annoncé
officielle mais ses rapports avec la
police comme m oui sauf que là c'est
globalisant c'est à dire que ça n'est
pas traiter un cas avec la punition qui
va avec
est ce que justement précisément
normalement c'est le rom de l'igpn et
c'est le rôle du ministre de l'intérieur
aussi de punir les cas donc il ya eu
finalement un laxisme du ministre de
l'intérieur au moment de la punition et
finalement il lance une phrase comme ça
qui vient globalise ans et qui laisse
entendre que c'est une réalité donc je
crois qu'il ya eu un là aussi peut-être
une erreur de communication
même si évidemment dénoncé les faits qui
sont à dénoncer ça fait partie de la loi
et ça fait partie de son obligation
je signale juste une chose parce qu'il
marquait castaner et les lycéennes ayant
pour sa part ça c'est parce que aussi au
vote cette eau vive et ce mouvement des
lycéennes qui demandait de pouvoir être
habillé comme elle le voulait dans les
geeks écoute mais sur le coup sûr le
point précédent quand même ce qui est
important de comprendre à mon sens assez
de la différence qu'il ya quand on dit
violences policières et des violences
dans la police et c'est une forme et
c'est le même le mettre là même
mécanisme que le racisme c'est à dire
c'est quand on désigne un individu comme
représentant l'ensemble de son groupe et
par conséquent on condamne tout le
groupe
là où il est il est effectivement
entorse et qu'il a donné l'impression de
condamner l'ensemble du groupe et qu'il
y ait des gens racistes dans la police
il y en a comme ya des racistes
malheureusement partout on en a parlé
tout à l'heure qui est des gens violents
dans la police il y en a effectivement
quand ils ont détecté ils doivent être
condamnés c'est pas pour autant qu'on
prend toute la police qui je le rappelle
elle va ramer de la république va
respecter les lois les lois et qu'on dit
tout la police est violente et puis
ensuite il ya la violence pardon ya une
violence justifier aussi dans certaines
arrestations
certainement pas celle qu'on a vu
récemment mais dans les locaux du
quotidien je veux dire si vous venez
demain elles encourent à la clé de saint
pierre il voyait dans les conditions
dans lequel on la déserte appellation
simple qui se passe il n'y à face à la
violence que de réponses que la violence
quand on veut maîtriser quelqu'un la
notion est dans l'équilibré ce qu'on lui
a reproché c'est effectivement donner
une vision hyper caricatural est dans la
réaction du temps de l'ensemble du corps
il a dit la police est raciste noms
méconnus
non mais il y à du racisme dans la
police quand on est mise d'intérieur et
d'ailleurs le président public
on lui reproche aussi à parler de
violences policières et or on lui
reproche aujourd'hui on va il nous reste
à peine 2000 trois minutes on va ce mois
d'octobre
[Musique]
alors évidemment il ya eu leur
confinement et hull à faire samuel pâti
en homo est ce que vous pensez qu'il y
aura un avant et un après à faire ça
mais elle pâtit
je crains que l'on vous connectant je
crains que non malheureusement
jean-charles après la ferme il n y aura
pas d'après la faire patte il n'y aura
pas d' après tout le monde de baisse les
bras et du monde s'en tire l'aident pas
se construit c'est finalement la
succession les événements c'est à dire
que justement on se déconfit non croit
un peu que la vie va reprendre et on se
rencontre on voit la con qu'on retombe
sur une autre une autre violence quelles
que fussent elles de la santé mais celle
de la de la terreur finalement est bon
je sais pas s'il y aura un après
j'espère j'espère c'était jeanne mance
au jeu
j'allais dire comme charlène j'espère
qu'il y aura un après et j'ajoute que ça
dépend aussi de chacun d'entre nous
chacun l'a willet chacun avec les
leviers dont il dispose peut essayer de
faire avancer les choses en expliquant
convaincant et en ne laissant pas
impressionner
jean baptiste moi je suis plutôt dans la
résignation en charge
même si j'aimerais un vent d'optimisme
de stéphane je suis vincent moi je pense
qu'il va y avoir un avant et un après
mais pas forcément dans le bon sens
c'est à dire que la presse a recent la
plus d'auto censure de la part des
enseignants et à plus de lois
sécuritaires qui en fait ne change pas
grand chose mais on l'adoré comme quoi
même les morts parfois enfin espérer
qu'elle soit au moins utiles on va ce
mois de novembre alors novembre c'est
l'espoir du vaccin
quand même qui arrive est alors ya eu un
petit petit croquis dans le parisien je
voudrais qu'on leur montre c'est très
intéressant
ça montre aux fous qu'eux
barre à gauche au centre on est pour le
vaccin plus en vain à droite est plus
franc des contres est ce que est ce que
non c'est vrai par exemple marine le pen
veut pas se faire vacciner
est ce que est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut avoir une lecture politique du
vaccin alors franchement vous me
l'apprenez parce que c'est pas le
sentiment que j'ai en local j'ai vu ce
que j'ai beaucoup d'amis de droite qui
ont tellement confiance en la science
qui serait même fait vacciner dans la
phase une sans faire les tests et je
connais beaucoup de gens de gauche qui
ferait de même
je suis très surpris en fait de cette
étude bon non je sais pas ce qu'on peut
en tirer moi personnellement je me suis
fait vexé contre la grippe alors je suis
au centre alors donc je pense que je
dois encore effectivement les cibles
vaccin oui interviennent
oui c'est vannes bon évidemment oui jean
baptiste bien sûr vincent oui justin
juste un mot sur la question de plus à
droite plus dans l'ailé droite plus on
veut se faire vacciner c'est que souvent
ça correspond en fait à la commande et à
la sociologie aussi des sphères
complotistes et des publics qui sont
plus touchés par les théories
complotistes sur ans ou des pertes plus
élevées et donc potentiellement donc
forcément plus plus fort plus souvent à
droite et des populations jeunes de
danse et retiennent certaines zones
urbaines etc
donc c'est assez cohérent en fait jean
charles oui bien sûr après le solide
vraies questions savoir quels vaccins
privilégiée mais elle a l'air de la
découverte est absolument formidable des
seniors
je peux plus je peux plus je peux plus
gestion passe juste au mois de décembre
parce que c'est l'apothéose décembre
[Musique]
décembre c'est le président qui est
positif est-ce que c'est pas la
conclusion la plus géniale de l'année
génial je ne sais pas ce que je vous
souhaite pas d'être malin en vous
ouais la plus symbolique en tout cas ça
al'avantage ans un avantage politique
c'est le rapprocher encore plus des
français est de dire après tout il est
comme tout le monde il peut être
contaminé donc il peut en tirer un seul
bénéfice probablement c'est celui de se
rapprocher encore plus des fonds auprès
des français deuxième peu deuxième
avantage c'est qu'on est content de
recevoir à versailles dans les yvelines
il est présent sur toujours les
bienvenus s'ils reviennent à versailles
à la lanterne
c'est tout un tas le prince charles le
prince albert avait absolument juste
pour conclure peut-être bon c'était une
année noire
j'ai le time l'année la pire d'histoire
il ya quand même peut-être quelques
lueurs d'espoir c'est dire que dans ce
monde gouverné par l'argent on avait
quand même qu'à la solidarité et qui a
beaucoup joué
et puis j'y reviens quand même mais le
génie quand même des scientifiques parce
que ce ce 1 et rennes ce vaccin et
rennes c'est absolument génial quoi qui
miment le coronavirus pour faire croire
que il attaque de nos cas je trouve ça
absolument extraordinaire
un peu quelques espoirs il est certain
que si on se rapproche au grand grandes
épidémies comme la grande peste exterran
moyen-âge aujourd'hui en on se rend
compte que c'est extraordinaire on
arrive à produire une forme de quelque
chose qui sauve des vies très rapidement
dans des conditions absolument
effectivement qui n'ont jamais existé
dans l'histoire donc ça doit nous
rassurer
je pense que ça doit nous rassurer de
plutôt de futures épidémies parce que
malheureusement ce n'était pas la
première mais ça ne sera pas la dernière
il y en aura d'autres les virus mutent
tous les jours on sait pas ce que demain
de quoi demain sera fait et donc la
science effectivement sort malgré toutes
ces hésitations je rappelle que
l'incertitude fait partie du calcul de
la cense son grandi dessous cela m'évite
ya deux ans je pense qu'on n'aurait
jamais imaginé de faire un vaccin non
dans ce cas même si comme le disait
massot certains pensaient que le vaccin
existe à vous le virus
merci merci à tous merci à tous on vous
souhaite évidemment de très bonnes fait
une très bonne fin d'année abandonné
merci
bah aux téléspectateurs de 3 2 lyon des
hauts de france et de la normandie et à
très vite pour un nouveau numéro de
boeuf
merci à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]